delighted to have dr. Stephen red here
tonight from CDC and I'll tell you a
little more about him in a moment first
of course the hertog global strategy
initiative is a research program in the
Department of History that implies
historical analysis to confront present
and future problems in world politics
and examine how history can illuminate
the future and improve decision-making
so I think it's entirely very much in
keeping with the theme to have tonight's
speaker we thank the hertog Foundation
and Roger hertog for sponsorship this
series is also co-sponsored by the
Center for the history and ethics of
Public Health at the mailman School of
Public Health and we thank them for the
co-sponsorship as well as the Columbia
University global strategy seminar of
which this is a part and we also thank
the mailman school communications office
for the refreshments that hopefully you
will all be enjoying and have a chance
to enjoy it's really a privilege to have
dr. red here tonight he is as you can
see from your program a Rear Admiral and
assistant Surgeon General in the US
Public Health Service and the director
of the influence of coordination unit at
CDC and so he was actually the incident
commander who directed the CDC response
to the last influenza pandemic you
remember h1n1 from last year from 2009
and supervised over 3,000 people in that
massive and very impressive effort he
started at the CDC as many have as an
EIS epidemic intelligence service
officer and has had a variety of jobs at
CDC before rising to his current
position and I suppose if in the next
few years we have another pandemic you
will again be leading the charge so it's
really a pleasure to welcome a real
admiral steven read tonight he'll talk
about influenza pandemics in context and
to welcome all of you thanks very much
and it's a pleasure to be here to talk
with you about influenza epidemics or
pandemics of the of the past and future
as for the most part I sort of see a
range of Ages but for the most part
meters of tomorrow I'll describe some of
the challenges that we've confronted in
the past and I hope that this will be
will be helpful to you as your careers
move forward and you face similar
challenges in the future what what I
plan to do tonight is to review three
pandemics of the past century nineteen
eighteen nineteen fifty-seven and then
the 2009 pandemic and I'll do two things
in these reviews the first is I'll
provide some measure of context I think
that that these events are often
compared one against the other without a
real appreciation or our consideration
of the events surrounding surrounding
the the pandemic and I think that really
is it's it's unfair and it leads these
things are inherently different but
Larten for a large way different because
of the circumstances surrounding the
event and the second thing I'll try to
do is communicate the uncertainty that
was taking place at the time the events
unfolded both from what was happening
and also the decisions that had to be
made I think in looking back it's hard
to appreciate its really the job of
historians I think to remove that sense
of uncertainty that was I was taking
place and to kind of come up with the
truth but as the event is being
experienced going forward it often is
unclear what's really happening and what
ought to be done we have the next slide
so some of the ways that I'll provide
context I'm sorry before I provide the
context what I'm going to do is talk
about influenza viruses a quick review
and I think some of this may have been
covered in other in other lectures this
is a cartoon version of influenza a
virus these are RNA viruses they have
eight single strand genes and they're
known by the surface proteins
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase you can
see the blue bars there are a pictorial
representation of the hemagglutinin
antigen this is the the protein that
binds to cells and allows the virus to
enter the neuraminidase shown as the
green blobs here is sort of the the exit
the protein that allows the virus to
exit the cell so influence a viruses are
known by their hemagglutinin serogroup
and neuraminidase your group and so
you'll see numbers like h1n one or h3n2
or h5n1 and these are all influenza a
viruses next slide there are 16
different hemagglutinin serotypes only
three of those are normally circulate or
circuit have circulated ever in human
populations and so seasonal viruses up
to this point have been either h1 h2 or
h3 and either in one or into but there
are a lot of other hemagglutinin and
neuraminidase influenza viruses
influenza a viruses out there these
mostly are these circulating animals
mostly in birds but also pigs horses
dogs and other animals and the the
seasonal viruses have the they naturally
will drift as the immunity and a human
population develops to the virus they
will change ever so slightly to evade
that population immunity so they're
changing every every year drifting a
little bit
it this is why seasonal influenza
viruses have to change periodically but
influenza a viruses also have the
ability or the occasionally will change
very dramatically so that there's no
immunity in the population and when this
kind of shift takes place we have the
possibility of an influenza a virus
causing pandemic next slide so when a
when a new combination of genetic
material and an influenza virus makes
itself known the question is does this
virus have pandemic potential the
newness of the viruses is a given what
that means is that there's no immunity
or very little immunity in the
population but the virus also has to
have the ability to transmit efficiently
from person to person and it has to be
in a setting where sustained
transmission can take place so these
characteristics create or identify a
virus that could cause a pandemic a
pandemic of course is a worldwide
epidemic for if it's an influenza
pandemic it's an influenza a virus novel
influenza a virus that's transmissible
among humans there are two things about
this definition that I'd like to point
out one is that that it doesn't say how
bad the infection will be so you can
have a by this definition you could have
a pandemic with a relatively mild
disease that's not very severe and the
other thing about this definition is
that is actually backward-looking so
that when a new virus emerges this has
all these characteristics you can't say
that it's a pandemic virus until it's
already spread around the world next
slide I'm going to move now to some of
the elements of context that I'll be
talking about during during the talk the
first is this picture of capital
obviously but the political situation in
the economy are things that do affect
the response and at times the
a response can actually have political
implications next line this slide shows
a modern emergency department with capab
technology that was unimaginable in 1918
and not available in 1957 next slide for
influenza there are specific
technologies that are available now and
for the large measure hadn't been as
available in the past so the ability to
make a specific diagnosis the
availability of vaccines and the ability
to make vaccines against the specific
virus that's causing the pandemic
antiviral drugs and then the supportive
technologies in intensive care unit
treatment mechanical ventilation in the
instance where the lungs can't do the
work in antibiotics for the bacterial
complications of influenza next line we
also have the ability to to prepare to
use these tools and this is a picture of
the Emergency Operations Center at CDC
during one of our exercises where we
tested our ability to to respond to a
severe influenza pandemic next slide and
ultimately the the main determinant of
the even with all of these other issues
the society the medical care our
preparations the virus itself really
determines how bad the pandemic is going
to be next line we have worked at CDC on
measures of measuring the severity and
the transmissibility of influenza
epidemics and pandemics and we've come
up with this index you can see under the
parameter column these are things that
can be measured and can be scaled the
higher the number the worse so the
symptomatic attack rate in an outbreak
investigation that
school what proportion of people became
ill in a household investigation and the
are not the reproductive number how many
cases result from a single case or does
a single case produce and then the peak
percentage visits for for
influenza-like-illness next slide and
similarly for the severity the case
hospital is eight the case fatality rate
hospitalization rate and the ratio of
deaths to hospitalization next slide so
you can scale this these letters are
arbitrary and the grid lines arbitrary
as well the upper the upper right is
worse is the worst and the lower left is
the least worst and i'm going to show
you where some of the the seasons and
the pandemics of the past have fallen on
this on this scale next slide let's
actually we're going to now switch to
1918 and I'm through this talk I'm going
to show you some videos will bring some
people in to talk about influenza in
this case we're going to talk we're
going to see some of the things that
we're going on during nineteen eighteen
days
well it's a little bit we knew there was
going to be a risk of the sound not
working what you're seeing is a is a
parade at the end of World War one and
the really intending to dramatize the
effect that World War one had on society
in the u.s. we have the next slide
ok
so what was going on in in 1918 well the
US was heavily involved in world war one
massive mobilization of the population
and of doctors and nurses to be in the
army a lot of control of society as a
result of the war you can see some of
the other things airmail people trains
where the main way people got around
long distance travel and Nobel Prize for
quantum physics next slide GNP was one
trillion dollars this is adjusted for
current dollars so 113th or so the size
of the economy today you can see that
there was a federal deficit in 1918 with
about four times more expenditures than
that then intake largely because of of
World War one and then you can see some
of the other the other measures there's
well butter I guess was a lot more
expensive in 1918 than it is today next
slide so the technologies that were
available that I showed in that previous
slide there wasn't much in 1918 viruses
hadn't been discovered there were no
anti-vaccine anti virus vaccines there
was a lot of work being done on
bacterial vaccines we didn't have
antibiotics antiviral drugs didn't exist
and I think mechanical ventilation was
probably a science-fiction kind of idea
but there were things that there were
things that could be undertaken which
I'll talk about in a couple of minutes
so let's look at what happened during
the pandemic next slide this figure
shows the non-combat related mortality
in the Navy and what it shows is fairly
low mortality up until the second week
in September and then a very dramatic
spike with a decline over
about the next six weeks next slide
during the nineteen eighteen pandemic
around 30 million or more people in the
world died upwards of half a million
people in the u.s. god and there was an
unusual age distribution of those deaths
normally in seasonal influenza and in
this figure the pandemic that had
occurred about 20 years before very
young and very old are most likely to
die in the nineteen eighteen pandemic
there is this w shape with 20 to 40 year
olds having a very high risk of death
next slide so on that grid that I
described earlier the 1918 pandemic is
the kind of upper right outlier where
you'll see more transmissible than other
seasons or pandemics and much more
severe next slide
these are some other other sort of not
exactly representative but other years
for which we could find data and you can
see in that a box the latin of lower
three are all from recent seasons of
influenza next slide
okay I'm sure we're going to have sound
injury
why don't we go to the next slide and
apologize for these these technical
difficulties especially may be the last
one I'm going to show is from The Daily
Show and so I hope we can we can get
that one not so we're going to move now
to what interventions were undertaken
and there were things that were done
previous life different cities did
different things to try to reduce
transmission and what you can see in
this figure is the difference in the
experience in Philadelphia and in st.
Louis I'm in Philadelphia of early and
dramatic peak of disease pretty rapid
fall off in disease and in st. Louis
much lower and much delayed Pete
mortality and lower overall mortality as
well next slide because of the war in in
Philadelphia there was a parade to raise
money so that people would buy Liberty
Bonds this took place just right at the
very beginning of the virus being
introduced into Philadelphia next slide
in in st. Louis a little bit later based
on the experience of other cities and on
local leadership a lot was a lot was
done to society was essentially closed
down if you give me another tap these
measures were put in place for a little
bit more than a month the closing order
was withdrawn and then not instantly but
at some later point there was an
increase for a second a second or a UH
the the highest peak actually was
delayed until that point in time next
slide
when you look at the date of this paper
because it's something that I think we
have learned more about the nineteen
eighteen pandemic in the last ten years
than in the period between the pandemic
and ten years ago it's been really
studied quite a bit more recently than
it had been previously in this this is
really a systematic examination of the
two slides i showed you before of
looking at what different cities did and
whether it did anything to reduce total
mortality the time to the peak and the
height of the peak and the bottom line
is that the earlier that these non non
pharmaceutical or societal interventions
were undertaken the more effect they had
on reducing excess deaths relative to
places that they've been later is a
little bit less strong in overall
mortality and the delay to the peak to
the peak mortality I'm gonna what's so
what what does all this mean
nopes here so cities did things to to
try to intervene these efforts were not
systematic in a national way they
weren't really organized although in
some locations they were highly
organized there was no national
leadership and there was also no call
for national leadership during this
event the medical and public health
infrastructure just wasn't in place to
do this at a national level and I think
this is really a paradox given the
severity of the event that there wasn't
more of us or the national recognition
and response and it may have been that
the war is the cause of that the 1918
pandemic has been called The Forgotten
pandemic and I think it is true that at
least in the immediate aftermath that
didn't really have a major impact on the
national consciousness or on public
health so now let's move to to 1957
let's see if we can
okay what this is this is President
Eisenhower giving the state of the union
address in in 1958 it's it is in between
the two two waves of the 1957 pandemic
and if you could hear him he was talking
about the threat of the Soviet Union and
communism next slide the things that
were going on in the country largely so
the Space Age was beginning the civil
rights movement was in a somewhat early
stage Toyota started selling cars there
was some element of control of society
not I don't think quite the same degree
as in 1918 but the house on American
Activities Committee was underway and
blacklisting of writers in Hollywood was
was a part of that era next slide you
can see that the GNP had increased about
4-fold since 1918 there was a federal
debt and again there was more being
expended than being brought in the
federal deficit of twelve percent
average income had gone up a little bit
and then you can see the rest of those
rest of those measures there makes like
from the medical standpoint ultrasound
was being developed the first nuclear
reactor was put in place in in
Philadelphia again as are in
Pennsylvania and again the threat of the
Cold War the Soviet Union was developed
the hydrogen bomb it tested it and the
the Sputnik and the space space race at
the gun next slide in the 1950s medicine
had developed quite a bit since the
since the nineteen eighteen pandemic
viruses had been discovered vaccines
against viruses were in use the polio
campaign in the US was just two years
before the 1957 pandemic influenza
vaccines had been produced there was
emerging understanding of the drift of
influenza vaccines and that they had to
be updated periodically from from the
standpoint of respiratory support
technology the iron one was the best we
could do not maybe would work for polio
but for someone with pneumonia probably
not going to have a big impact and
antibiotics were in were available and
available to treat treat pneumonia after
influenza next slide
okay may-maybe what we'll do is we'll
play all the videos at the end of the
talk so this is a morir silliman who is
the indenter Ur and discover of most of
vaccines in use today 57 we all missed
it the military misted and the World
Health Organization missed it but I saw
an article by Joe and the New York Times
which said that they were homies
children were being taken to the
dispensaries and one gong 20,000 people
lined up and I looked at that they said
baby's head glassy-eyed stare so my god
this is the pandemic it's here so I said
I've Japan got virus specimens and did
quick analyses and by George I was able
to announce to the world and I had guts
at that time I said that there will be a
pandemic which would start when school
began in the fall and it didn't let me
down the pandemic of 57 of Asian
influenza began on time but now and
again early detection very early
detection in that alert from the New
York Times not from science then allowed
us and I could go to the manufacturers
and get them going on an immediate basis
without having to
go through the bureaucratic red tape and
we might help the manufactures along we
had 40 million doses of vaccine by the
time that that the end of the year came
and it was used that's the only time
we've ever averted a pandemic with the
black scenes so this this map shows you
the spread of the h2 into virus that
caused the 1957 and then they first from
from Asia you can see South southward
into Australia South East Asia eastwards
of Japan and then westward throughout
the rest of the world next slide so so
this is what happened worldwide 124
million deaths and in the u.s. around
seventy thousand deaths I would I would
hate to dispute dr. Hillman but i'm not
sure that the 1957 pandemic was really
prevented you can see the two waves of
mortality here during 1957 and then into
1958 the the the second wave occurred
primarily in older individuals this I
think also this scene this way with
different age distributions was
something that we fought a lot about
during the 2009 pandemic so
next slide so the 1957 pandemic falls
into this quadrant be a lot lower level
of severity than the 1918 pandemic but
more transmissible by those measures
than any of the other other reference
reference seasonal epidemics so from the
1957 pandemic we had the ability to
identify the virus and to make vaccine
and there's no doubt that that vaccine
prevented some disease it's hard to know
exactly I don't think all 40 million
doses were used but it's hard to know
exactly who got those doses and what
amount of disease they they prevented I
think that if we look back there's an
interesting contrast between the polio
work done just a couple of years before
and relatively silent response to the
1957 pandemic public health again with
polio being a major exception wasn't
nearly as developed as it is today the
CDC have been existence for a little bit
more than 10 years but with the
exception of the polio campaign I don't
think Public Health was quite at the
level of maturity that it is at now so
in maybe some of this is just just has
to do with influenza that it it came it
went there were no chronic sequelae of
influenza and it sort of passed from
consciousness it's possible that the
Cold War had some effect on this but
that wouldn't explain the 19 the polio
work next slide
so now let's shift forward to the
current era just to set the stage and
for the people who are at the session
earlier some of this is going to be
quite repetitive but I there are several
events that occurred in the first few
years after 2000 that I think set the
stage for preparing for h5n1 and then
the response to 2009 September the
events of sep tember 11 and particularly
the anthrax bioterrorism and then
afterwards in public health's response
for it with to it I think raised some
questions about the capability of public
health and being able to respond to a to
a major event in an emergency like this
in in the Czar's episode the main thing
that was learned is that the open
sharing of information is really
critical to an effective response and
was delayed several months before the
world knew that there was this new virus
out there Public Health once once that
recognition was made public health
responded effectively using very basic
infection control measures and then
Hurricane Katrina where the the
inability to evacuate the population
really pointed out some lack of lack of
plans and lack of ability to execute
that really showed that government there
was a role an important role for
government as as part of these
emergencies so those were all the things
that we're going on before the video
that I hope we can show that has
President Bush announcing the efforts to
prepare for the next pandemic
the nymph George Bush called on Congress
to approve of 1.2 billion dollar plan to
create enough vaccine to protect 20
million Americans against a deadly
strain of bird flu he says the US as
well as all nations must take all
preventive steps possible a flu pandemic
would have global consequences so no
nation can afford to ignore this threat
and every nation has responsibilities to
detect and stop its spread mr. Bush said
the United States must be prepared to
detect outbreaks anywhere in the world
so in 2006 the threat of an h5n1
pandemic was just public currency there
was a made-for-tv movie in the spring of
2006 next slide
there there was reason to be concerned
this map shows cases of h5n1 in poultry
that and the extent of spread over just
about a two-year period of time
beginning in Southeast Asia spreading
south and in Indonesia and and westward
through through the rest of Asia Europe
and into into Africa this really is not
something that had ever been seen before
next slide and there were also human
cases a relatively small number of cases
but with a mortality rate of about two
thirds and you can see that the cases in
the way we're sentinels for the disease
in culture particularly next slide this
this event and I think particularly the
leadership from very high level spawned
a really intensive planning process with
plans from the White House from Health
and Human Services next slide and also
from CDC and we in the spring and summer
of two thousand six developed an
Operations plan we had an intensive
exercise program and conducted actually
five functional exercises so this is
when we're in the emergency operation
center there are there's information
being fed in that we're supposed to be
need to respond to and really really
helped organize us to make the decisions
and to understand what information we
needed to make those decisions during
during a possible future event and this
was very much focused on h5n1 and a 1918
type pandemic next slide and we actually
had some real life practice that in May
of 2006 there was a cluster of h5n1 k
indonesia three generations of
transmission all in the family there was
a lot of talk of this this was going to
be the pandemic I turned out that after
that third generation there wasn't
further transmission you will notice
that some of these events had New York
as the as the locusts but in March of
2007 a traveler returned from China with
pneumonia had been on a poultry farm we
thought that this was the beginning of
spread into the United States it turned
out and that person didn't couldn't have
aged five in one and then not very not
very much later a physician from
Pakistan traveled to the US this was at
a time when it wasn't known that
Pakistan had a tribe in one he reported
that his brother had died from a tribe
in one he wasn't feeling too well it
turned out that he also did not have a
tribe in one but this really was the
kind of thing that would expect it would
be happening that there'd be a sentinel
event that we would respond to I'd say
that a lot of these plans were based on
a there's different ways of calling this
but it would in the UK they call it a
reasonable worst-case scenario so what
in the realm of possibility is sort of
still possible but really bad and there
was also an assumption that the this
this pandemic would be starting overseas
and that there would be time to detect
it before it arrived in the united
states that we have maybe have a chance
to contain the outbreak at its source
and that we at least have several weeks
to prepare within the united states to
get ready to are sort of our domestic
response but as we know that's not what
happened next slide
I'm now going to be relating a lot from
personal experience that on a Wednesday
April fifteenth at a regular meeting of
the pandemic Response Group there one of
the parts of that was that there have
been a case of a virus that had never
been seen before it was a swine flu a
similar related to swine flu in a
ten-year-old boy it was actually
identified it's part of a clinical trial
of a diagnostic test device that was
designed to identify h5n1 also seasonal
influenza and at that time it was so
swine flu cases are identified every so
often and normally within a little bit
of Investigation person had been at a at
a fair or on a farm and that wasn't the
case for this individual but two days
later second case was identified from
Imperial County so the first case was
identified by the Navy in San Diego the
second case in Imperial County we
reported that information a few days
later and then on Wednesday the 22nd
additional cases were identified from
Texas and at that time who knew that
these know these cases had exposure to
pigs none had exposure to each other we
knew that this was probably something
significant was going on but these were
all mild cases at the beginning in fact
several of the cases had recovered
before they were diagnosed and then on
April 23rd that really that was really
the big news that in autopsy material
sent from Mexico to Canada and to CDC
the number of instances of h1n1 swine
the swanton thought related to swine flu
viruses were identified and we had a
real
so the two different sets of information
a few very mild cases from the US all
the cases in Mexico have been fatal and
we didn't know if we were missing severe
cases or if Mexico was missing mild
cases or if there was some combination
or maybe it was it was more developed in
a more later in Mexico than in the u.s.
to some extent these questions I think
still actually remain next slide this is
rich Besser three days after the let me
provide for you an update in terms of
where we are today and what kinds of
public health actions are being taken
here as well as abroad today we can
confirm that there are 20 cases of swine
flu in the United States we have five
affected states there are eight cases
confirmed in New York City there's one
case confirmed in Ohio two in Kansas to
in Texas and seven in California and
again as we continue to look for cases I
expect that we're going to find them
we've ramped up our surveillance around
the country to try and understand better
what is the scope what is the magnitude
of this of this outbreak so on that day
there were a lot of decisions that had
to be made and some some of which were
made this list of the things that we had
to decide down to about the last for all
of those took place within the during
during April within the first week after
the detection of these cases in Mexico
the
the contract with industry was probably
in mid-may and funding to States was
something that we knew we were going to
have to do that didn't actually get
executed until the summer and then you
can see these last two last two bullets
that the vaccination program was
initiated on October fifth but I just
think back on the number of cases that
were reported on on April 26 then how
little was known about what was going to
happen next slide we know that this did
become a pandemic this figure shows the
estimated number of cases so kind of
extrapolation from laboratory and
hospitalization information there were
four weeks where more than five million
cases occurred per week similar to 1957
the the big peak was in the fall we did
not have a winter wave in the way that
was that occurred in 1957 next slide so
at the at the end of the pandemic the
estimates for the number of cases was
around 60 million with most of those
cases are with the risk being highest in
the youngest age groups for
hospitalizations about a quarter million
with a fairly even H distribution and
around 12,000 with a pretty wide range
around twelve thousand deaths occurred
with the highest risk in the fifty to
sixty four year olds people that had
high-risk medical
ditions next slide so at the end of the
day the 2009 pandemic ranks as the least
severe by this on this on this scale of
the pandemics that we've talked about
but more transmissible than seasonal
influenza which are those those three in
the lower lower left corner let's move
now to the interventions that were
undertaken next slide this is top Tom
Frieden I think you recognize the
director of CDC now the flu vaccination
program for h1n1 is going to be
challenging in a normal flu season with
lots of time for preparation with years
even decades of practice working with
provider groups and others we vaccinate
about a hundred million people over
about four months what we're looking at
now is vaccinating as many people as
want to be vaccinated in as short a
period of time as possible and there are
enormous logistical challenges to doing
that next slide the main logistical
challenge was having the vaccine what
this figure shows it's the same figure
cases in orange and then in green are
the deliveries of vaccine and what you
can see is even though we started
vaccinating in in early October it
wasn't until late November and December
that that production and distribution
reached we really got to the the maximum
doses and the during this period of time
there was a very sort of a teeter-totter
between not enough vaccine and too
demand to exactly the opposite where we
had more more vaccine and less demand
thanks 5 so there were a lot of things
done well during the pandemic we rapidly
identified the virus we developed and
distributed diagnostic reagents
throughout the country and really
throughout the world so there was a
foundation of knowledge about the about
the disease we vaccinated around 80,000
80 million people and used the something
that had been available in Prior in
Prior pandemics antiviral drugs that
next slide you'll see that we prevented
5 to 10 million cases through the use of
vaccine prevented around 30,000
hospitalizations with that broad range
and from vaccination alone a thousand to
1,800 deaths we think about 6 million
antiviral courses of treatment were used
preventing between 8,000 and 12,000
hospitalizations and four to six hundred
deaths and if you look at the title
that's the some sort of taking the
lowest estimate of what was accomplished
next slide so so how did we do
do that don't don't we have to show a
certain baseline level of competence
yeah well I mean I'd argue that we have
shown a baseline level of competence the
thing is that when you show a level of
competence it doesn't become a story it
only becomes a story when they're our
problems take the h1n1 flu for example
right we jumped on that quickly not some
people criticized this for being too
aggressive on it but I think we averted
a larger public health disaster and
there are many examples that's a fair
that's absolutely a sharp point we're
gonna get a commercial so here's what
we're going to do because this happens
to me all the time we get a nice
interesting conversation and then Comedy
Central decides they need to sell beer
and so we're going to go to commercial
we'll talk for a little bit longer next
slide so just to sum up and maybe in a
little bit of a different way what we
learned is that the work that we did
before the pandemic was very important
in our ability to respond even though
what we were preparing for it was
different from what occurred vaccine
production was too slow and we
miscommunicated on the availability of
vaccine that we gave excessively
optimistic and specific projections and
those that that really was a very hard
to overcome during during the event the
everyday systems bullet what I mean by
that is that the things that were in use
all the time for seasonal influenza and
routine public health really formed the
foundation for the public health
response so things like distributing the
vaccine we use the same system that's
used to distribute vaccine day in and
day out the surveillance systems used to
track the disease the systems used to
assure that the vaccine was safe all
those things were things that happen
happen every day and lastly the
importance of communicating
that this really was a foundation of the
response the transparent regular open
communication of what we knew and what
we didn't know next slide
so this is Secretary Sebelius is going
to give a quick introduction to where we
are headed with medical countermeasures
the counter those threats and cities and
towns across this country but as we
studied the landscape it became clear
that one area is where we needed to put
a special focus on medical
countermeasures medical countermeasures
are the vaccines antivirals antibiotics
diagnostics and medical equipment in a
public health crisis they are most
direct and often our most effective
defense to reach our national stockpiles
most countermeasures travel along the
exact same path they begin with
discovery in a lab then the discovery
gets translated into a useful product
then that product gets tested for safety
and effectiveness and then someone
manufactures it and if the process works
well there's a steady output of new
countermeasures targeted at our biggest
potential threats but the closer we
looked ok I'm going to translate the
five elements of this medical
countermeasure initiative I think if you
read these bullets it might be kind of
hard to know what what we're talking
about but I'll decode these for you
first of all we are partnering with
manufacturers to build factories that
can produce influenza vaccine and other
countermeasures on demand this is a
really major initiative and will make it
possible to have going forward much more
rapid production of pandemic vaccine and
other countermeasures secondly NIH is
working to take ideas from the idea
stage to the product stage more quickly
FDA will be working to
smooth that regulatory process making
sure that the products that we have are
safe and effective but making sure that
they're also available quickly there are
some specific things related to
influenza vaccine and influenza
countermeasures in this initiative and
finally the US government is proposing
to work as a venture capitalist with
small companies to help them have the
resources available to take innovative
ideas to products next life just to
dwell for a moment on influenza vaccine
production there there are really three
different horizons for this work in the
short term working to make sure that we
can quickly measure the amount of
vaccine in the vial that's what's known
as potency using modern methods to make
sure that the vaccine is sterile rather
than having to culture it and waiting
days and weeks to make sure that it's
sterile and then making sure we've got
the the factories that not only if we've
got bulk vaccine that we can put it into
vials and two syringes quickly in the
medium term moving from making vaccine
in eggs something that's been done since
three vaccines have been made to making
them in cell so that we can make much
more vaccine and then to the long term
getting to a situation where we don't
actually have to grow the vaccine but we
can move to more if growing the vaccine
and eggs is a kind of an agricultural
process moving is something that's more
industrial and doesn't require that
growth process next slide so for an
effective public health response we need
these are the elements of that rapid
detection faster development of
countermeasures including vaccine and if
there's a need for a different kind of
antiviral drug
reliable distribution and dispensing and
then the workforce to do that work and I
think another really kind of underlying
capability is the ability to communicate
effectively last line I want to close
with where we are with a chive in one
and it may seem like it there's no more
cases of h5n1 because it hasn't been in
the news certainly not since the h1n1
pandemic but you can see that cases are
continuing to occur Egypt Bangladesh
Cambodia and Indonesia have reported
cases this year there's no reason to
think that really less likely to have a
pandemic in 2011 or 2012 and in 2006 or
2007 close so I just want to wrap up for
a moment here and just how do we put all
this together we've had these these
three pandemics in 1918 there was there
was little ability to respond from a
medical standpoint there were
interventions undertaken at the local
and individual level but at a larger
level public health really didn't have
the tools to respond that were developed
later in 1957 there were tremendous
advances in medicine so the disease can
be diagnosed a vaccine can be produced
but there wasn't a large-scale public
health campaign which is a little bit
surprising given the most pandemic that
was most recent that was was so severe
and again as I've said earlier maybe
that is the nature of
the winds that it passes quickly through
a community most cases or mild even even
when summer failed for for 2009 a lot
went right from the early detection to
the sharing of reagents to make sure
that we had a global picture and the
country's knew what was going on in
their own countries but these this delay
vaccine is as part of the legacy of 2009
and you've seen that there's a lot of
work underway to make sure that that
doesn't happen the next time just kind
of us at a little bit higher level I
think we should expect that for the
future as our abilities to respond grow
there's going to be an expectation that
we're able to respond that may even be
greater than what we're able to do and
this is part of the communication
revolution that's taking place we know
that we'll have to do those things that
I showed as the measures of an effective
response detect respond with with with
products and be able to deliver them and
be able to communicate I think we can
also be sure that the next pandemic will
be seen even more as a global event that
even though all these pandemics have
been global I think that there would be
a global nature of it that will be
greater than what we've seen in the
pandemics that have occurred up to now
so thank you very much thank you
the floor is now open for questions for
dr. red do we have a microphone okay so
just be cloud Lee okay please stand up
and just down
and it seems like a lot of the contents
and a lot of meat public media like
talked about how government will be
committed to find way too much vaccine
that turns out
yeah I think that the the problem with
the vaccine production was really the
cause of vaccine being purchased that
was an administered because by the time
we had the vaccine the demand for it had
declined the decision-making process is
such that you have to make the decision
to buy several months before the vaccine
was actually delivered I think on the
whole the the work that was done was to
make sure that there wasn't a situation
where we could have purchased vaccine
there was demand for it and there was
disease that could be prevented so that
that was that had a lot to do with the
way the decisions were made I would hope
that we would use that same formula for
the future and that the purchase of
vaccine was really looking at it in that
way I think that we not knowing what was
going to happen several months down the
road it was safer to have vaccine rather
than not having thank you for your
I wanted to have about and this is a
more general question but it pertains to
rapid detection and the cc's work in
general it seems that we spend a lot of
money for example on national security
threats like terrorism every time an
incident perseverance
well the NYPD sends out intelligence
officers to investigate we're building
rockets kills and full body scanners at
airports and things of that nature what
and at the same time not many people
died of terrorist attacks but you said
12,000 people died at 30,000 people with
dives does the CDC act in a similar way
are there investigators that go out if
the new disease occurs to mess they take
samples and and is there the same
interagency cooperation between for
example the Department of Homeland
Security the Defense Intelligence Agency
as there is when it comes to other
nationals yeah I think there is kind of
a different construct where the work
that we do in public health is done
collaboratively both within the US and
outside of the US we we monitor closely
trims and disease and want to know
what's going on wherever it's going on
throughout the world we work to build
capacity of countries to be able to make
make diagnoses and determine whether
something is going on so I think the
there is a lot of collaboration that
goes on we do send teams to try to find
out what's going on in collaboration
with different countries and with with
state health departments there's
probably another piece to the puzzle
that's that's not in the in the
landscape that you painted that's a
little bit different in that the World
Health Organization is also an important
collaborator in public health and so
there are lots of people trying to know
what's going on I think also there's not
the need for secrecy in the way that
some of those other areas there are in
fact it's just the opposite that the
more people know everything that's going
on the better the better we'll all be so
i think that there's some things that
we're doing that are along the lines of
what you're saying
the whole perspective is really
different so would you say stands in
relationships is the efforts so the
question was that so as I my comparison
was ok terrorism not many people die
every year is would you say the money
being spent on the efforts undertaken to
take preventive measures and detect
early are in relation to yes yeah is
there one touch yeah I guess the the
frame of reference that i have is among
other among health threats so i think
there's a lot of work being done to
detect events overseas could more be
done for sure I don't know that we can
really make these kind of comparisons
across these different disciplines to
sort of say you know do cost-benefit
analyses or those kinds of things
and I was struck by your use of the
language of sorts the level of social
control within 19 and 57 and they
currently and I was I'm just interested
in sort of how someone who is
professionally in cbc and someone coming
in from my perspective not with a
navigator already training that can sort
of talk about what that means that sort
of level of social control and what's
the concept of that as it pertains to
the endemic experience and and also the
sort of public memory of it has to do
with that yeah no I think that's one of
the themes of the talk and I guess based
on recent experience what I would say is
that there is decreasing ability to do
anything like that probably a good thing
but it also creates a certain amount of
chaos and requires a different set of
skills I think from public health and
what might have been used or might have
been available previously which is the
risk communication strategy of open
communication acknowledging uncertainty
and try to answer people's questions to
promote a degree of trust that in those
prior instances there are other ways of
sort of gaining compliance I guess
my question is about bioterrorism and
how we should kind of prepare for that
kind of situation because you may have
more than one pathogen going around at a
time obviously and so maybe as a country
that's trying to handle one pan diffic
at a time should be maybe like divide
that and have like the cities' be more
control of focus on other states so they
have more power on their own to joshy
yeah no I think that cities and
localities have a lot of authority and
in fact in an even in the that probably
came out most clearly in the in the
nineteen eighteen pendant maybe not
altogether as a positive I think there
is a balance between a national view and
global recommendations but those have to
be applied locally and so I think there
is appropriately a lot of authority at
local health departments and state
health departments and that's really the
way it ought to be I think one of the
things in the in the 2009 pandemic is we
recognize that you know we were doing
these things but the work the real sort
of putting shots in arms and collecting
specimens happen at the local level so
really the work that's done on the
ground it's not happening in Atlanta
it's happening where the disease is do
you guys do you think that the local
authorities have an a funding right now
and are prepared for that kind of
situation currently well I think there's
I think what we've seen over the past
few years is that funding for public
health both at the state level and local
level has declined with the budget
environment that we're in so i think
that is regrettable and it would be
better if that weren't the case
hi um I was just curious given how with
the Asian influence on 57 New York Times
played a key role in combating that and
then contrasting that with a couple of
years ago with h1n1 how our 24-hour like
news machine kind of perhaps overhyped
it some extent because it needs fuel I
suppose um do you think the press play
is more of a positive or negative role
today and how we deal with pandemics
yeah well I think that the the role of
the press is what it is and it's it's up
to us to communicate effectively and to
use use have the press play the role
that it ought to which is to describe
what's going on it's up to us to
communicate effectively what what that
is what what's known was not really that
that that risk communication strategy
that I talked about earlier I think that
there is such a demand for information
that it does put a burden on public
health but I think to a large extent the
media can operate as a megaphone and to
amplify messages I think and I think
that in in large part that's what
happened during to that for 2009 p.m.
thanks
and feel free if you want to take the
microphone in your hand and do a sort of
karaoke a question period please feel
free thank you all decline this was a
wonderful talk and I just have a
question about your comment of about the
NIH doing venture capital hmm now as you
are well aware there have been problems
with vaccine manufacturers not least the
anthrax people and as you also well
aware there were problems with
manufacturing i think in england in 2009
in and so i'm wondering just how this
venture capitalist to work because with
biotech companies usually they're
unsuccessful very few unsuccessful and
also usually now there are all sorts of
licensing sales in the rest and the drug
development process which goes on for
many years which of course the vaccines
wool is shepherded by Big Pharma so I'm
just wondering how this this seed money
or whatever it's to be is is is is going
to work or as or is it going to follow
the Big Pharma model and and and have a
standard vaccine manufacturer then take
over yeah well first of all it wouldn't
be NIH as the strategic investor so
exactly how that would be set up it
would probably have to be something
somewhat separates from government I
think that the the idea would be that
there that these would be products that
big pharma wouldn't be that interested
in so things that a small company might
have an idea and have it to a certain
point where it could be taken to the
next level with resources that maybe you
wouldn't have a market but but there be
and so there'd be a need for this kind
of ability to take an innovative idea to
the next level I think that the
the i think that the points that you're
making are important ones and whatever
is done this shouldn't be just sort of
handing money over it's got to be a
benefit to the government it's really
the public to the benefit of the gut of
the public in a way that wouldn't occur
without it and so that that's really the
idea that there's some of these these
products that are getting to a certain
point but they're you're not able to get
beyond that and this is another way to
try to goose them along but I agree with
you that we things like who's making the
money and does these the pose this
really a benefit to the public or key
questions
government so I'm wondering to what
extent we're finding small
pharmaceutical firms developing
innovative influenza vaccine just called
and I president also interested in this
randomized clinical trial that was about
the 900 realized that was the way that
sure sure one of the one of many
priorities acted upon in preparing for a
pandemic was to develop a test that
could be used almost at the bedside but
a portable device that a hospital or
doctor's office could buy that could
make a specific diagnosis of influenza
within 30 minutes and so this was a
prototype device that was being used
that you know take a clinical specimen
put in the machine 30 minutes later you
get a result the result that that was
obtained was that this was there's an
influenza by the person was infected
with an influenza a virus but it wasn't
like any of the viruses the seasonal
viruses or h5n1 so according to that
protocol it made its way to CDC and
that's how the first case was identified
I have to say that that in that protocol
there was a lot of discussion about
whether this was the right thing to do
because there might be a lot lot of
false positives there'd be a lot of
specimens coming to CDC that would be
wouldn't be flu but that that's the way
that that first case was detected I
think so your first question innovation
is really critical and I think one of
the challenges is the market for these
products that we have we have flu
vaccines now they're very safe there
perhaps not as effective as we would
like them to be but the ability to
due to sort of take something from an
idea all the way through the process to
a competitive marketplace is really huge
challenge and and there really are not a
lot of incentives to do that because
there is a product that can be sold its
effective and so that really I think
this idea of the strategic investor is
to try to use market forces effectively
to make the right things happen from the
public standpoint where the existing
that existing balance is it doesn't
doesn't seem to be getting kind of
products that meet that we need sir as
you know from history look at strategy
military campaigns had fallen because of
the high disease rates civil war most
that's been watching on disease we look
at that contemporary national security
problems I want to know what has been
going on in terms of the HIV AIDS
infection of African sultry which was
raised as an issue of national security
apply the president I believe this
here's this question of what's going to
happen inside these societies with high
rates of HIV infection I wish I could
answer that question by liking it and
not mean I just don't know are there
more questions don't be bashful feel
free after the 2009 pandemics you feel
we're better prepared now for the next
pandemic I think that we are definitely
better prepared I think there's a risk
though that we we sort of think we're
more ready than that we really are we we
conducted an exercise this past March
that was kind of back to the original
version of an h5n1 an endemic and I
think it was surprising to many people
including me the things that I've
forgotten in a year and some of them
very mundane but I do think that there
is a danger of many dangers one is
complacency that we know how to respond
to an influenza pandemic the second is
that we assume that the pandemic that we
have is what will be what will have in
the future and i think that's that's a
very great risk and i would say that
probably if i was going to make one
prediction is that whatever we think is
going to happen something different will
for influenza pandemic and I i think
that the ability to sustain this as a
high priority is going to be challenging
thank you are there any other questions
if not please join me in thanking
Admiral red for that excellent lucid and
multimedia talk
you